shopping online has become a booming
industry but with all of success it
seems like some online retailers aren't
too concerned with the quality of items
they are sending their customers if you
are a first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button to see more videos like
this today we are discussing ten biggest
online shopping fails Packaging fail for
years consumers have had to blame their
packaging woes on postal deliveries but
the rise of internet shopping has led to
a whole new problem like this person who
just wanted to make her mother's
birthday extra-special the customer gave
specific instructions to the online
retailer to keep the package
inconspicuous but it looks like the
person packaging her party supplies
didn't get the hint and this very
obvious box arrived instead furniture
for ends it can be a tedious task
shopping for furniture and decoration to
fill a new home so it's no wonder people
turn to the internet for all their
furniture needs it's easy there are no
crowds and you don't have to put pants
on unfortunately these customers must
have missed the dimensions unless they
are furnishing a house for and they are
probably going to be a bit disappointed
with their new purchases toddler
clothing there are only so many stores
like caters a toddler clothing so that
makes the internet a perfect place to
get unique and one-of-a-kind pieces to
make children fashionable sadly what
seems like the perfect pink Easter dress
for this little girl turned out to be a
total mess or this cute puppy jacket in
reality is just a knockoff version with
cute pins attached to it or this sweet
tutu awesome that is a completely
different outfit than advertised
Oh Christmas tree Christmas time
decorations are huge for retailers so
online stores decided to cash in on the
profits purchasing reusable Christmas
trees is nothing new but buying them
online is so when these customers
thought they were scoring a great deal
on a tree they could enjoy for years to
come they were a bit let down these
trees look completely different in the
description photo and probably only
decorated the nearest dumpster camp ah
star doormat it's not like there's a
special store someone can go to buy the
perfect doormat
so turning to the internet to find a
doormat seems like a reasonable idea
that is until the doormat actually shows
up this person thought they were getting
the perfect out doormat to greet their
guests but instead what showed up was a
piece of foam with the photo of the mat
they purchased attached to the top the
only redeeming quality about this
purchase is the fact that it is
technically still a gray door mat
sweating dress disasters one of the
biggest expenses of getting married is
the wedding dress
so when bride's fine they can pinch
pennies by getting a custom dress online
they jump at the opportunity but many
find that their dream dress ends up
being their worst nightmare most of the
time what they think they were getting
is actually a far cry from the photo
from different colors to changing
details to things just not fitting
purchasing a wedding dress online
usually proves to be a negative
experience that should be avoided
flower power thanks to online flower
shops find the perfect bouquet for a
loved one is easier than ever but a lot
of times purchasing a flower arrangement
online can be a real gamble like when
this person thought they were getting
their mother a suit bare arrangement but
what showed up look more like Casper the
Friendly Ghost or this person whose
mother was incomplete Mother's Day shot
when she opened her box of fresh air
that's right the flowers were missing
completely Thank You Internet jewellery
fails because of all the deals and
variety of selection shopping for
jewelry online can be awesome but there
are times a cheap price tag comes back
to haunt the buyer this woman thought
she was getting an authentic mineral
rough necklace but what arrived was a
cheap spray painted rock attached to a
chain then there's this girl who
ingested and compute pity rings only to
find that her rings really look more
like creepy cat skeleton custom prom
dresses less like online wedding dress
makers the internet is full of custom
prom dress knockoffs but purchaser
beware these dresses aren't always as
amazing as they seem in fact these girls
found out their prom dresses were a far
cry from what was advertised online this
girl thought she was getting a
one-of-a-kind crimson dress tailored to
the size but when it showed up and
looked like someone had butchered the
original version of the dress the moral
of the story is just say no to
online custom gowns fluid substitutions
the Internet has made everyday life so
easy that people can order groceries to
be delivered without having to leave
their bed but what happens if the item
they want is out of stock when this
happens the store takes it upon
themselves to substitute that item with
something they believe is similar but
most of the time they completely missed
the point like when these stores thought
that dog food and treats for a good swap
for cat food and treats or when this
store surprises customer with five cans
of evaporated milk and a pregnancy test
you know just to show they care what do
you think of these online shopping tales
react in the comment section below and
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things
[Music]